bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de quelque chose avec lequel on est tous
familiers c'est les couleurs alors les
couleurs c'est une des premières choses
qu'on apprend à reconnaître par exemple
quand on est gamin
et pourtant on se pose souvent des
questions par exemple qu'est ce que
c'est déjà vraiment une couleur est ce
que le blanc c'est une couleur le gris
le rose
et puis pourquoi il ya des règles pour
mélanger les couleurs qui sont pas les
mêmes suivant que c'est la peinture et
de la lumière
alors aujourd'hui on va essayer de
comprendre tout ça et pour faire ça on
va s'amuser à prendre une comparaison
entre les couleurs et les sons et vous
allez voir c'est assez instructif
si on parle de couleurs du point de vue
sensorielle on parle bien sûr de notre
vue et donc on parle de la lumière et la
lumière physiquement c'est une onde
électromagnétique
alors quand on considère une onde une
caractéristique importante dont on peut
parler c'est sa longueur d'onde la
longueur d'onde c'est en gros la
distance qu'il ya entre deux crêtes du
signal électromagnétique une onde
électromagnétique elle peut a priori
avoir n'importe quelle longueur d'onde
et suivant cette longueur d'onde en fait
on va lui donner un nom différent
par exemple si la longueur d'onde est à
peu près de 1 m on parle d' onde radio
etc les annonces bas qui servent à
transmettre la radio si la longueur
d'onde elle est plutôt autour du cm on
parle de micro ondes et oui c'est
évidemment les ondes qu'il ya dans les
micro ondes mais pas que si on va voir
des ondes beaucoup beaucoup plus petit
par exemple avec des longueurs d'onde de
l'ordre du nanomètre ou en dessous c'est
ce qu'on appelle des rayons x
en fait les rayons x bats c'est comme
les ondes radio et les ondes micro-ondes
ce sont des ondes électromagnétiques et
alors là dedans
les ondes que l'on peut capter avec nos
yeux c'est à dire les ondes qui
correspondent à la lumière visible
elles ont des longueurs d'onde qui sont
situées en gros entre 400 et 700
nanomètres et là il ya déjà un truc
remarquable à noter parmi tout le
spectre possible des ondes
électromagnétiques notre vue ne permet
d'en distinguer qu'une toute petite
partie 1
celle dont les longueurs d'onde sont
comprises entre 400 et 700 nanomètres
alors qu'un priori des ondes
électromagnétiques eh ben il en existe à
toutes les longueurs d'onde 1 depuis le
nanomètre et même en dessous du
nanomètre jusqu'au au maître et même
plusieurs mètres je vous ai promis que
dans cette vidéo on allait s'amuser à
comparer les couleurs et les sons alors
rappelons brièvement ce que c'est qu'un
sont à son c'est aussi une onde
mais c'est pas une onde
électromagnétique c'est une onde de
pression de l'air pour les ondes sonores
on peut aussi parler de leur longueur
d'onde mais c'est plutôt habituel de
parler de leurs fréquences c'est à dire
du nombre de vibrations qu'elles ont à
chaque seconde la fréquence et la
longueur d'onde c'est en fait deux
facettes de la même chose en réalité
elles sont reliées par la vitesse de
propagation de l'ondh
mais bon allez savoir pourquoi en fait
pour la lumière on a plutôt pris
l'habitude de parler en longueur d'onde
et pour le son on parle plutôt en
fréquences alors l'unité de la fréquence
c'est le hertz donc là par exemple je
vous fait écouter un son qui est à 440
comme pour la lumière notre oreille elle
n'est pas capable de détecter toutes les
ondes sonores
alors ça dépend des personnes et l'âge
mais en gros notre oui elle est sensible
aux sons qui sont compris entre vingt et
vingt mille hertz 20 hertz et les sons
les plus graves est en dessous on a les
infrasons et 20000 hertz et les sons les
plus aigus qu'on peut percevoir et au
dessus c'est ce qu'on appelle les
ultrasons voilà ça c'est lé petit rappel
concernant le son mais on va revenir à
la lumière et surtout aux couleurs alors
imaginez que je prenne une onde
électromagnétique dont la longueur
d'onde avec 400 nanomètres et que je la
balance dans votre oeil
qu'est ce que vous allez voir et bien
vous allez voir ça du violet si l'on
avait une longueur de 450 nanomètres ça
serait plutôt indigo à 5 100 nanomètres
du bleu vers 550 du verre un peu en
dessous de 6 ans du jaune un peu au
dessus de 600 du orange et à 650
nanomètres et jusqu'à 700 ça serait du
rouge
donc si je vous balance dans votre oeil
des ondes lumineuses dont la fréquence
est comprise entre 400 et 700 nanomètres
la perception que vous allez avoir c'est
celle de couleurs qui balaye ce qu'on a
l'habitude d'appeler les couleurs de
l'arc en ciel
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre dans cette
affaire c'est que la couleur c'est avant
tout une perception c'est un truc qui
est fabriqué par notre cerveau au départ
les ondes électromagnétiques elles n'ont
pas de couleur un elles ont une longueur
d'onde
et c'est seulement une fois que ça
arrive dans votre oeil que votre cerveau
l'interprète et que ça vous donne une
sensation qu'on a pris l'habitude
d'appeler les couleurs alors on va
compliquer un peu notre expérience
maintenant imaginez que je ne vous
balancent pas une onde électromagnétique
avec une certaine longueur d'onde mais
que je vous balance deux ondes
électromagnétiques en même temps avec
des longueurs d'onde différentes par
exemple une onde dont la longueur
d'ondés 550 nanomètres et une autre on
dont la longueur d'onde des 650
nanomètres alors je vous rappelle un
normalement 550 nanomètres c'est quelque
chose qu'on voit plutôt vers et 650
nanomètre c'est quelque chose qu'on
verrait plutôt rouge
alors si je vous balance les deux ondes
en même temps qu'est ce que vous allez
voir comme couleur du rouge et du vert
en même temps bien du rouge et du vert
l'un après l'autre est maintenant vous
allez voir du jaune je pense que ce
résultat ne devrait pas trop vous
surprendra vous savez certainement que
quand on mélange de la lumière verte et
de la lumière rouge
on obtient de la lumière jaune mais bon
fondamentalement c'est quand même un
petit peu perturbant comme résultat ça
veut dire que si je vous envoie donc 2
de 550 et 650 nanomètres ça va vous
faire exactement la même impression la
même sensation que si je vous envoie une
selon de 6 100 nanomètres
on a vu une seconde de six ans après ce
pont et du jaune pour bien comprendre en
quoi ce résultat il est vraiment bizarre
voudrais qu'on fasse la comparaison avec
les sons et la musique
allons-y là je vais vous jouez un dos
1re et amis
maintenant attention je vous joue le dos
et le mit en même temps
si vous me concentrer un peu vous pouvez
entendre distinctement le dos et le mit
un musicien avec une bonne oreille ils
seraient même capables d'identifier les
deux hommes jouent ensemble sens que
j'ai besoin de dire quelle note c'était
donc si je vous jouent deux notes en
même temps vous pouvez les distinguer
toutes les deux alors que si je vous
balance deux ondes électromagnétiques en
même temps vous voyez une espèce de
moyenne des deux vous rendez pas compte
que ces deux ondes
si notre oreille elle marchait comme nos
yeux ça voudrait par exemple quand je
joue un dos et amis simultanément vous
entendriez 1re et 1
très bizarre non si c'était ça
d'ailleurs la musique ce serait
vachement pauvres seraient incapables
d'entendre des accords
à la place on entendrait juste des
espèces de note moyenne
ça serait un peu chiant
donc on a vu qu une différence
fondamentale entre notre ouïe et notre
vue c'est que nos oreilles elles sont
capables de décomposer les différentes
fréquences d'un sont si je joue deux
notes en même temps mon oreille
reconnaît qu'il ya deux notes alors qu'à
côté de ça notre vue elle est incapable
de faire la différence entre jaune et
vert mélangé avec rouge
alors pour comprendre d'où vient cette
bizarrerie en fait il faut se pencher
sur la manière dont fonctionne la
perception des ondes électromagnétiques
dans notre oeil sur notre rétine
il ya quatre types différents de
cellules qui servent de capteurs
lumineux
il ya les bâtonnets dont on va pas trop
parler aujourd'hui qui servent surtout à
la vision nocturne et puis il ya les
cônes dont il existe trois types
différents
les cônes ils ont un mode de détection
qui est vachement plus pauvres que les
tympans de nos oreilles par exemple
c'est à dire que quand un cône reçoit
une onde lumineuse
il est pas capable de reconnaître la
longueur d'onde de la lumière la seule
chose qu'il est capable de reconnaître
c'est qu'il a reçues lumineuse et donc
d'envoyer un signal du genre ah ouais là
j'ai repéré un truc et est fait ou alors
la petite particularité c'est que les
trois types de cônes que nous avons ils
ont des sensibilités différentes aux
longueurs d'onde de la lumière
on a des cônes qui vont réagir aux
longueurs d'onde autour de 450 km des
côtes qui réagissent vers 550 nanomètres
et d'autres plutôt dans la zone 600 650
nanomètres alors par raccourci on a
tendance à appeler ses cônes les cônes
bleu vert et rouge
alors c'est quand même une petite
entorse parce que vous voyez que le cône
rouge et quand même pas très très
éloignée du cou en verre mais bon
maintenant qu'on sait ça on peut
reprendre notre expérience où on
balançait deux longueurs d'onde en même
temps essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passe dans ce genre de situation le
codever il va particulièrement réagir à
londres qui est à 550 nanomètres
et puis le cône rouge il va plutôt
réagir à londres qui est à 650
nanomètres et je vous rappelle les cody
identifie pas la longueur d'onde la
seule chose qu'ils sont capables de dire
ca ouais là j'ai vu un truc
donc si vous balancer ces deux zones en
même temps les deux types de cônes les
cônes verts et les cônes rouges vont
tous les deux réagi en disant ah ouais
là j'ai vu un truc
maintenant si je balance une honda 600
nanomètres et ben l'icône verts ils vont
y être un petit peu sensible donc eux
aussi vont réagir et dire ouais j'ai
capté un truc et les cônes rouge bah
pareil ils vont réagir et dire ouais moi
aussi j'ai capté un truc donc on voit
bien qu'à cause de cette manière de
détecter on a deux phénomènes physiques
qui sont à la base assez différent c'est
à dire
zend à 550 et 650 nanomètres d'un côté
et puis une honda 600 nanomètres de
l'autre qui vont provoquer exactement la
même perception la même sensation ce
qu'on a pris coutume d'appeler le jaune
et ça c'est très important parce que ça
montre vraiment bien que la couleur
c'est pas un concept physique c'est
vraiment un concept biologique c'est à
dire que c'est quelque chose qui est
créée par notre cerveau c'est une
interprétation c'est une perception
d'ailleurs cette idée que de la lumière
rouge et de la lumière verte ensemble ça
fait de la lumière jaune ce qu'on
appelle de la synthèse additive je me
souviens bien c'est quelque chose que
j'avais appris en cours de physique au
collège mais c'est une connerie parce
qu'en fait c'est pas un phénomène
physique c'est vraiment de la bio la
synthèse additive sino connais tu es
différent
la synthèse additive se passerait de
manière différente la preuve un les
daltoniens il voit pas les couleurs de
la même manière que les autres et encore
une fois de ce point de vue là l'oeil
est quand même vachement moins fort que
l'oreille notre oui elle nous permet
d'entendre des accords et les très bons
musiciens sont même capables de nommer
les différentes notes désaccord c'est à
dire qu'ils sont capables de vraiment
des composés de signal sonore et de
remonter aux fréquences qu'ils composent
terre de remonter à la vraie nature
physique du signal à côté de ça notre
vue la perception qu'on a des ondes
électromagnétiques c'est juste les
couleurs faire c'est quelque chose
d'assez pauvre par rapport à la vraie
nature physique du signal une autre
manière de le dire c'est qu'on ne peut
pas reconnaître des accords de couleurs
alors continuons un peu notre
exploration des couleurs vous avez
remarqué que dans l'arc en ciel il n'y a
pas de rose
c'est vrai il ya du bleu il ya du violet
il ya du rouge mais il n'y a pas de rose
alors pourquoi n'y a pas de rose et bien
le rose c'est cette sensation que notre
cerveau fabrique quand le col bleu et le
cône rouges sont tous les deux excités
par des ondes lumineuses mais pas le
codever et vous voyez que ça peut pas
marcher avec une seule longueur d'onde 1
il en faut forcément au moins deux et
dans un arc en ciel en chaque point et
ben ya qu une seule longueur d'onde donc
il peut pas y avoir de lumière rose dans
un arc en ciel bon ça c'était pour le
rose est maintenant le blanc est ce que
c'est une couleur le blanc
là on a dit une couleur c'est une
sensation c'est une construction de
notre cerveau et donc le blanc oui c'est
une couleur et c'est plus précisément la
sensation que notre cerveau fabrique
quand les trois types de cônes sont
excités à peu près au même niveau et il
ya plein de manières de provoquer cette
sensation il suffit de trouver des
manières de stimuler les trois types de
cônes donc par exemple on peut le faire
en balançant des ondes ayant plein plein
plein plein de longueurs d'onde
différentes
c'est ce que fait par exemple le soleil
ou bien une bonne lampe à incandescence
ou bien on peut se contenter de balancer
juste trois longueurs d'onde qui vont
bien et qui vont venir excité chacun des
trois caunes et ça c'est le principe des
écrans lcd par exemple dans un pixel
d'écrans lcd en fait il ya trois sous
pixels un rouge un verre et un bleu et
ses trois sous pixels sont chacun
capable de vous balancer ces longueurs
d'onde spécifiques qui viennent exciter
vos trois types de cônes donc si les
trois sous pixels sont allumés vous
recevez les trois longueurs d'onde et
donc vous avez la sensation de blanc
alors tout ça attention faut bien voir
que je vous ai dit c'est un phénomène
biologique
c'est à dire que c'est lié aux cônes
qu'on possède et toutes les espèces
animales ont pas les mêmes types de
cônes il ya certains poissons comme le
poisson rouge par exemple qui ont quatre
cônes différent il ya des oiseaux par
exemple le pigeon quand mon 5 et le
record ça serait une espèce de crevette
qu'on appelle la crevette menthe et qui
en aurait entre 12 et 16 le poisson
rouge par exemple il a un quatrième
caunes qui est dans l'ultraviolet ce qui
veut dire qu'un poisson rouge qui
regarderait une télé lcd par exemple
pour lui ça serait pas une
retranscription fidèle de la réalité
parce que ça enverrait pas d'uv pour
nous si quelque chose et met du rouge et
de l'ultraviolet bas à nous on voit la
même manière que s'ils y mettaient juste
du rouge mais pour le poisson rouge ça
serait différent
je termine par un dernier truc amusant
au sujet des couleurs on l'a dit la
couleur c'est vraiment un concept
biologique un la physique
elle ignore complètement le concept de
couleur elle parle que de longueur
d'onde et donc si on considère un objet
par exemple un tee shirt et qu'on se
demande quelle couleur il a en fait le
tee shirt il n'a pas une couleur est la
seule chose qu il s est un spectre de
réflexion c'est à dire qu'il va
réfléchir d'une manière possiblement
différentes toutes les longueurs d'onde
de la lumière et donc un tee shirt qui
va réfléchir les ondes de 6 100
nanomètres par exemple il va nous paraît
john et un au petit short qui
réfléchirai les longueurs d'onde 550 et
650 et ben il va nous paraître jaune
aussi mais physiquement c'est pas le
même t-shirt
alors il ya deux manières de se rendre
compte que ces deux t-shirts qui a
priori ont l'air tout les 2 jaunes en
fait ils sont différents
pour ça on peut s'amuser à essayer d
éclairer avec une lumière qui soit
exactement de 6 100 nanomètres
on va le premier tee shirt vue qui
réfléchit la lumière assistant
nanomètres il va réfléchir et donc il
nous apparaîtra jaune mais le deuxième
tee shirts irréfléchie uniquement 550 et
650 il va pas réfléchir cette lumière et
donc il nous apparaîtra noir si on
balance toutes les longueurs d'onde en
même temps comme c'est le cas avec le
soleil et la plupart des lampes on voit
pas de différence entre ces deux tee
shirt mais si on s'amuse à les éclairer
avec des lumières qui ont des longueurs
d'onde très spécifiques
alors là la différence peut apparaître
une conséquence amusant de ça au coucher
du soleil vous savez le soleil
il a l'air un peu orangé et si on
compare ça par exemple avec les lampes
qui a dans les tunnels autoroute bas
elles aussi elles ont l'air orange est
donc on pourrait penser que c'est un peu
le même genre de lumière sauf qu'en
réflexion sur les objets qui nous
entourent c'est pas du tout pareil sous
un tunnel d'autoroute
tout al'air orange à ce alors que
coucher du soleil d'allah tout est très
beau et donc même si le soleil couchant
et la lumière d'autoroute
elles ont une vision directe à peu près
la même couleur en réflexion sur les
objets c'est pas du tout la même chose
et donc la raison c'est que la lumière
du soleil elle contient toutes les
longueurs d'onde donc elle fait se
réfléchir toutes les couleurs de tous
les objets alors que la lumière de
tunnels autoroute en fait c'est une
seule longueur d'onde ou presque- centré
autour de l' orange et donc elle ne
permet de réfléchir que de l' orange
comme quoi la couleur c'est quand même
quelque chose de compliqué alors si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo je vous en
recommande deux autres que vous pouvez
aller voir pour aller plus loin il ya
une vidéo de syllabus qui parle
justement de la couleur des t-shirts et
notamment elle nous montre comment
construire un spectre au avec juste un
bout de cd et de webcams c'est assez
amusant et puis une vidéo de bruce de y
penser qu'ils parlent des cônes et
notamment des conneries
j'ai de la manière dont ils ont évolué
et dans notre perception du rouge a
évolué au cours des temps merci d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo si elle vous a plu
comme d'hab
n'hésitez pas à la partager et des mois
à faire connaître la chaîne vous pouvez
me retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
pour les actus de la chaîne sur facebook
sur twitter vous pouvez me soutenir sur
tipi si le coeur vous en dit merci
beaucoup à tous les types heures qui me
soutiennent et puis vous pouvez aussi
aller voir mon livre j'ai sorti ça il ya
quelques jours c'est un livre qui
s'appelle mais qui attrape et le bison
guys et donc il est disponible dans
toutes les bonnes choses
merci et à bientôt